[Applause]
[Music]
okay so today we are going to learn how
to do silk ribbon spinning dancing
ignore my hair I just came from a photo
shoot in them really all fancy that I
don't usually look this good but we're
gonna be doing silk ribbon spin dancing
I don't have the clothes for it I forgot
to get shorts but I think it'll be okay
because I'm not gonna be too good at it
and I don't think I'm gonna get sweaty
unless I get good at it or something
like that bump I forget what the
person's name is probably like a Susan
or something or Jimmy your Jackson hi
I'm here to dance on silk ribbons maybe
that one that works okay oh thank you
what's your name I'm John John thank you
so much John that is a cool car my vans
better though you know you got it no
trying to show off so either way I think
that was probably the lady that's gonna
teach me the silk ribbon dancing unless
I'm being horribly sexist and it's
actually John cuz that's entirely a
possibility but just going by my
personal bias I think it might be that
lady okay I'm beginning points I think
he's just pointing to the lady being
like oh this lady is the one
hey let's do this hello everybody my
name is markiplier and this is Taylor of
the dancing fire is it like your stage
name or is it a company name or the
company the company name okay today
we're gonna be learning aerial silk din
ribbon dancing aerial silk dancing there
is that the real name aerial silks top
off the rest of that aerial silks so
Taylor is gonna guide me through a lot
of warm-ups and then we're gonna try our
best to do some activities so you want
to give them that sample I know you just
did this fancy not but yeah just review
what Taylor expects me to be able to do
at the end of today well first I want
you to climb to the top I'm gonna have
you do what we call double foot locks
and splits so I'm gonna make two foot
locks here and we're gonna slide out to
slits all right you see the the level of
complexity from just going up to that I
feel like there are a few steps in
between I'll get you on there and then
the next thing that we'll do is what we
call straddle back okay just give me a
close oom in on my face because I'm
gonna be doing a lot of these and I want
you to capture every one I'm gonna be
very dead by the end of this okay
crewmate so we'll get started with give
something for the foot people on you did
you know that's a big thing like even on
twitch which is a live streaming
platform you can't have bare feet while
you're live streaming cuz it's just
against the rules and they'll be in your
channels yeah I was thinking you're
saying it's a go weird fetish thing
that's the reason why you can't do it
it's like it's a because it fuels
people's fetish things and so but right
now it's just getting weird stop zooming
you're left 25 jumping jacks okay okay
one two
[Music]
okay and then last a little bit of the
warm-up or new ten jump squats so we're
gonna squat down and explode that's one
we're doing this nine more times one two
nine last one yeah so I'm gonna have you
do I'm gonna have you arch chance a nice
slot back down perfect and you can pedal
out your feet i alternate pointing and
flexing here okay this is like a pole
dancing move a lot of pedaling dizziness
five kicks on each leg doesn't matter
which leg you do first we're gonna do
both I'll demonstrate here one one nice
switch legs
five nice jump now what I want you to do
is swing one leg out in between your
hands here I'm gonna stick my right leg
in between my hands first come into a
runner's lunge you would your back knee
locked out and straight okay it's really
important here that your knee does not
go past your ankle okay there we go
I'm gonna go do some yoga blocks this
might help you why the pink oh no I
don't think my color yeah so if you can
you know walks by your side to help
balance and bring your chest up you can
do that unless you can do it without the
block all I can do now I'm gonna have
you stand it on up drag this back foot
in about a foot and a half blocks uh-huh
stick it underneath at the arch of your
friend's butt flexing the toes up toward
your face oh you should feel a deep
stretch yeah see I never stretched this
much for the other ones I feel like that
was really good my definite yeah I would
have done much better gotta be limber no
to yourself everybody you gotta be
limber always stretching always stretch
this time our knees going on the ground
and we're pointing our toe behind us
when you're ready you're gonna reach
back if you have your right leg forward
you're gonna reach back with your right
hand to grab your left foot okay Loney
action yeah make sure you're breathing
go ahead and release and we're gonna
push back into an ahall a reverse lunge
okay gonna straighten the front and bend
the back
it's really important that you keep your
quad engage in this nice straight as you
come in and I'd rather come you come
down with a nice flat back right there
rather than hunching over that's
beautiful right there I can't go any
more a little bit I had some good
McDonald and sink it down here I stretch
last week when I did my Beachbody
workout I've stretched I'm just not a
very flexible person as a child I was
very flexible and then my bones
solidified and this is what I am now and
I can rock forward and back comfortable
slide out okay I think you're you're
making a lot of assumptions about my you
keep talking about my split how long
would it take me to get a real split
doing that every day probably like four
or five months how can I do it intellect
a week I don't want to get your hopes up
I tell you a week has anybody ever done
it in a week from my place but I can
help you if you really want to split
let's see how today I'll decide before I
changed my career I'm only doing the
other way other side now exactly so left
leg comes out in the front back knees
locked out and straight we're on that
back toe here oh we're doing the whole
thing yeah that's me what they say about
me it wasn't perfect then you said
perfect I don't want you to call him
what coddle me on this
knee behind the toes yes that's where my
main man Sean T always says Beachbody
Coach Sean T
call me he's a real cool guy probably
hates me
[Music]
I don't see any difference between our
forms I haven't think about this if I
just stretch 10 minutes every morning
I'd probably be so much happier so many
things okay and you're gonna rock side
to side and we're gonna come up and over
onto one side so I'll demonstrate real
fast so I'm looking up towards the
ceiling my arms reaching above my side
reaching over yes
now I'm gonna pivot your torso so you're
dropping your chest towards your knee
and your nose toward your toe same leg
though ah I get you I see what you I'm
picking up what you're putting down I
get you suspended when I'm spilling yeah
haven't heard that one but I may use it
for you and you're gonna come down with
a nice flat back just like we did with
those reverse lunges your shoulders
yeah I'll get there hang on three two
one so you're gonna split the tissues
okay there are two shoes oh you come to
shoes or fabric or silks what do you
called all of it the above so I can we
split the tissues your hands are gonna
come from the outside to the inside to
the outside to the inside one more time
and now I'm gonna reach up high okay
so what I'm gonna have you do first is
go on your tippy toes here and they're
gonna pull up put a lot of people like
to think it's a pull up however it's
just your shoulders they're called
shoulder shrugs so if you look it's just
my shoulders that are engaging here okay
my elbows are not bending I'm just
lifting my shoulders I want you to
imagine new string coming from your
sternum lifting you towards the ceiling
okay all right so one more time
reach up Oh perfect go onto your tippy
toes tippy toes okay and bend your knees
when he's perfect and I want you to
imagine the string lifting you here yes
one you last one ten okay was I supposed
to keep my toes off the ground I did do
that I do that their shoulders aren't
used to that but I think you're strong
enough that you can hold yourself up no
he'd be real hungry that's so wrong okay
well now I'm gonna make you all get off
the ground a little bit of exercise is
so just like we did before the outside
inside outside reach up as high as you
can
we're gonna tuck your knees toward your
chest ten times okay this this is like a
test to see if I can even do something
you're evaluating my yes cool okay
tippy toes bend knees and then and he's
the chest yes I'm gonna do one last
little bit of thing on the fabric for
you get started so of course I like to
call this like the hammock hanging so
it's just a really nice way to stretch
and kinda get used to being upside down
and suspended by the fabric so I'm gonna
make a knot here in the fabric on this
fabric
like a backpack I'm gonna find this foot
in the tissues put it on like a backpack
okay here I'm going to invert so I but
it's gonna go over my head I'm gonna
shroud on my legs just like we did in
that stretch with the wide legs straddle
legs lift up they stay on the outside
they come in the middle I will fall out
right so keep your legs on the outside
outside from here you can stretch and
then what I'm gonna have you do is cross
one leg over both tissues and drop this
one behind you can stretch here and
switch sides of course so coming out
compact that shuttle position hands come
up here drop your legs yet it's that
easy huh just like that okay like like a
backpack I haven't been in school in a
long time so just I just go for it go
for it wide legs though wide leg wide
legs that's what they call me
wide leg markiplier do I just jump you
can jump and lean back
[Laughter]
okay so now I want you to cross one leg
over both pieces of fabric and drop this
leg behind behind
yes can you grab that foot oh yeah
beautiful awesome and switch sides when
you're ready oh I'm ready out oh you're
a natural
I'm a natural ah my hips squeezing me
when you're ready you can go ahead and
come back to that straddle position with
your legs and drop your legs you can
come right out okay how'd that feel
being upside down how good a little do
you need some water no good okay yeah
did you start on climbing I know won't
you get too burned out on climbing so
just give it a couple shots and then
we'll see where we get from there oh
okay okay okay so my right leg is gonna
come to the outside
okay wraps around to the inside back to
the
I'm flexing my foot here this is really
important okay
I'm gonna reach up really high my left
foot is gonna step right here I'm going
to sandwich the fabric in between my
feet okay from here I'm going to reach
up really high off my feet and climb
back up okay didn't see that one
so it comes free wrap the feet just a
little bit higher okay just like you're
going from the outside to the inside to
the outside one more time just higher to
come down slowly lower your hands down
looking a little puzzled do you want to
show you oh so it's same foot yes I
thought you were switching a wrap around
the other foot but I'm gonna have you
try it once on your right leg and once
on your left leg and see what you like
okay alright so it's here I reach up
high wait okay so I got a pull more a
little bit higher this fabric has a
little bit of stretch to it so if you if
you're wrapping your foot here when you
step you're gonna be on the ground right
here flex foot reach up high grab tight
I used to do rock climbing all the time
yeah two years ago two years ago I'd be
so good I'll have you try on your left
side when you're ready what happened
yeah I was still buff once upon a time I
wouldn't climb twice a day oh god four
hours McDonald's McDonald's breakfast
I'm good alright left side you're good
leftie fine there used to be no joke no
all serious are you
I used to have calluses like my used to
have crazy calluses I was like climbing
hell like I I went so bad that my
fingerprint scanner on my phone wouldn't
read my fingerprint anymore that's how
much I climb I got a change I gotta make
a change okay after this okay so you're
gonna wrap your foot just like you would
for that climb little terminology so
this is my point in contact with the
fabric anything above my point of
contact I'm gonna refer to as the live
in anything below or you fer to the to
as the tail okay not the dead end
not the dead so I'm gonna use my free
hand my left hand to pull on the live
end above my point in contact I don't
agree it's luck this right here this is
the slack slack I'm gonna drape the
slack over the top of my foot six like
and underneath I'm gonna create a little
boot this is your foot lock I mean don't
release your hands or anything but
you're locked in inside your feet okay
to come out step down kick it off your
foot do you show you one more time no I
think I got this one this time
so same as before this way and then once
you do pull some slack wrap this way
over the top of your foot first the top
figure eight and awesome you got all of
your toes out which I like to see okay
okay go ahead and reach up high and
stand on that Wow now to be really
really pretty yeah put your foot moving
passe yeah let me forward knee forward
oh honey for yes I can you know I got it
let me do it passe step down okay and
I'm gonna have you take it off your foot
okay so no we're gonna kick right here
alignment kick her things all comes off
yeah that's easier cuz I'm not holding
myself up yeah you take this one step
further okay
my right leg is foot locked okay same
with yours an apostate my left leg my
left hand is gonna reach up high
my right hand is gonna reach out to the
side this is our lean out position
notice that my inner thigh is pressed
against the live-in right here your
thigh on live it yes don't release your
hands cut your locked in those normal
all the toes perfect
passe okay passe so left hand reaches up
high left hand up high
give me your right hand right hand
release my left
okay double lobster a little bit more
challenging because you're gonna be off
the ground for one of them okay so put
the tissues and you do that foot lock
but one on each fabric okay so I'm gonna
wrap my leg here but lock just like you
did before
okay I'm gonna have you do my right leg
is foot locked my right arm in French to
this fabric against no waste this kind
of cinches me in helps me be able to use
my right hand freely without having to
hold on I'm gonna wrap my left leg just
like I went from my left foot lock so it
comes from the outside the inside to the
outside okay right hands are gonna pull
slack drape the slack over the top of
your foot and underneath the step on
okay come out come into an l-shape
oh oh you can kick off the foot locks oh
alright so let's go for it
alright oh yeah I've already got this
yes slack whoops no much cuz you'll be
on the ground that's okay that's my go
up on up up okay
I like to have one hand on each fabric
there we go okay okay you're gonna bring
your right arm in front in front yes
okay okay so out out in out right
and to pull that fabric right hand oh no
reach up higher with your left hand
there we go and now usually right hand
to pull that slack hook over I'm not
enough I can feel it okay not quite
quite okay it's closed cinema okay so
take them off and try it how do you try
one more time you're right yeah I can
touch the ground
that's all right I'm dirtying your silks
okay kick kick off reach up high with
you left bring your right hand in hand
in pull there we go the top over and
under awesome both hands one on each
side one on the outsides again on each
side perfect how do you feel you're
comfortable here yeah no I could I could
do this yeah you're gonna put both hands
to one side oh there's no matter what
you do you're gonna do both okay and
they're gonna slide up to your split
with this leg in front on the left sorry
Oh hands left or which hands right go
ahead and stand up now I want you to
bring two fabrics together sit your butt
back one two times kick right here so
the foot comes off okay and you can use
your free leg to kick that off it's like
kick
how's that how's fun booze bud that's
fun
I'm getting less existential crisis the
more I do before you do it yeah not too
bad do that okay so I'm gonna have you
do one more thing with the splits before
I move on to the straddle back okay okay
okay so we're out onto our splits yeah
of course okay leading with my pinky my
pinky toes coming through the middle and
now to our split one more time the more
you do the tighter yet so don't go more
than twice I'd recommend to come out you
just go the opposite way so big toe is
leading through the middle and Oh to
mentally prepare for what is about to
happen to my body I can do this now just
adding a step I know what I'm doing and
I am strong they're nice and even right
a little a little I could I could pull a
little more slack okay both hands to one
side doesn't matter which side you do
inside split you you who you don't need
to your flexibility as you want so let's
have both hands in front leg um like a
baseball bat yes okay so you're gonna
rotate this way beautiful thank you can
you really sure right hand to be pretty
do you want to roll up one more time or
do you want to come out I'm gonna roll
forward okay I'm gonna do you got it oh
not the opposite direction roll
backwards and once more okay that grab
up come together and the oh hell
yeah kick kick him off dick that was
great that was really good yeah
how are your legs feeling well my legs
are fine legs are fine
I use using a lot of muscles that I've
never used before like in the inner legs
in the abdominal area
how are the forearms people tend to like
forum very cramped yeah rock climbing
I'm it's funny I just did horse riding
the other week using a lot of muscles
that you use for horse riding here
yeah the inner thighs squeeze with your
legs I'm apparently a natural at that
too so how I can do that no the
horseback ride the screams give the legs
that'd be weird for me to brag about
that move on oh yeah okay with shuttle
back I want you to foot lock in the air
which is gonna be a lot more challenging
so you're gonna climb up and you're
going to wrap that leg but you're gonna
use your left leg to use as the slot
creator to create that foot lock I'll
demonstrate once really slowly so I'm
gonna climb up once I'm gonna split the
fabric okay I'm gonna wrap my right leg
just like I would my left leg is going
to push this fabric over the top of my
foot and underneath to step off here I
can bring my right arm in front and it's
just like normal it's just hitting that
first one you just want to be higher yes
you want to be hired cuz we're gonna be
upside down oh I see this ladder here
you know I just want to point out humans
learn to beat gravity a long time ago
maybe we could use that grab pull step
okay I'll come back and when I come back
you challenged I can give you something
else to work on so you don't have to
foot lock in the air cuz foot logging in
the area is not I hate to say it I'm not
quitter but I don't think I physically
can and it pains me to admit it
yes me mark I'm admitting that I can't
do something but I will
well I've haven't done many things in
the past I just haven't admitted it when
I come back
i'ma be wrong and I'm gonna bring a
friend and then he's gonna be worse than
me by comparison
what's the less challenge on both
fabrics what you're a pro at I know bro
yeah bro could take my job signal didn't
wanna say anything okay you're gonna
lead with you meet through the middle of
the fabric okay and you'll come right
through torso and waist comes through
Wow sure with this don't go far enough
that you can't pull yourself back up
okay so you want to go to the farthest
part of your flexibility but still be
able to engage your muscles put yourself
back up okay okay then you're going to
shoot that leg the opposite direction
fantastic I'm up I split the tissues
shoe fabric and then top straight arms
yeah and bring your chest towards me all
the way through the middle Oh
so to come out bring your fabrics
together you know this beautiful lock
pick it right off hey how's that great
great it was awesome wasn't it yeah now
I go do the other foot for symmetry
right of course do i I would like you to
okay pointed toes beautiful shoot that
leg behind you
yes magnificent yeah okay so I like to
call this candy cane um so you're gonna
single foot lock just like you did you
can do either side my right legs foot
block so I'm gonna hold on to the right
side right I'm gonna drop my torso this
way and I'm gonna rotate around this
fabric so I'm dropping my torso do my
free leg my left leg here is gonna come
over the top fabric to push this one off
my calf Oh off my cap put pressure into
that foot to pull up and rolling to it
so left leg is gonna push this fabric
off my calf if it's a the new calf it's
really uncomfortable
okay give you some pressure to pull into
it and you're in candy cane won't you
come out both hands reach in front just
like a baseball bat rotate out the
opposite direction you came once twice
and get your knee out
are you right leg your left leg I'll do
right and then left I said I learn on my
right and I look better on my lap
perfect he comes through the middle you
come through okay roll up into it keep
going
okay so you have the fabric right in
between your chest here and balance foot
in passe remember the folks who you need
say the opposite direction you grab step
house candy candy canes pretty good the
thing that I'm learning is when I was
first doing I was squeezing every muscle
in my body now I'm squeezing just a few
muscle in my body
okay they're the ones that I need to
actually do it comes through left side
all the way through the middle go
through kickers
we go rest the fabric in your chest I'm
gonna give you a little spin there are
girls more fun with friends anyways yeah
yeah yay
okay I'm gonna wait no this is wrong
yeah am i it feels wrong do you want to
learn one more thing do you want to try
the foot lock in the air that's usually
where I go next so honestly I don't
think I could cuz I don't think I have
the upper body strength right now to
pull we're building it we're building
it's just an excuse to come back that's
all it is I'm milking it I'm milking the
content for all it's worth I'm just a
big scam but thank you I'm a natural
just like horse riding well honestly I
am gonna come back and I am gonna bring
a friend I've got a friend that's a
gymnast he's gonna look better at me
this than I am but he used to be a
gymnast and so you know he can do splits
flippy some results he probably ain't
natural
I mean he did the Rings and oh but he
hasn't done in a while saying that won't
be baby
hopefully wimpy baby and you know what
about your double foot locks and splits
and don't forget to be pretty with it
always always that's a big thing about
pole dancing - you always go look good
they'll be pretty good alright so thank
you where can they find you I teach at a
studio called urban aerial fitness it's
a fountain vallye huh
and I teach there four days a week okay
urban aerial fitness found valley
they'll be a link in the description
thank you so much for helping out I'll
let you know when we're back are we
gonna be here or that studio up to you
whatever whatever looks nice not that
this doesn't look nice
John well anyway thank you so much rune
to check out taylor ultimate aerial
fitness ultimate urban area our urban
area aerial fitness thank you so much
and as always we'll see you in this way
bye-bye